una nueva declaración conjunta para
renovarla del 2016 y la del 2018 la
Unión Europea de la otan sellaron un
nuevo compromiso de cooperación en
defensa colectiva
estamos decididos a llevar la asociación
entre la otan y la Unión Europea a un
nuevo nivel en particular para abordar
la creciente competencia geoestratégica
los problemas de resiliencia y la
protección de la infraestructura crítica
el refuerzo de esta Alianza también
tiene el claro objetivo de tomar nuevas
iniciativas sobre la guerra en Ucrania
las partes prometieron proporcionar a
los ucranianos todos los medios
militares necesarios para defender su
territorio además de nuevas sanciones a
Rusia y a sus aliados
la Unión Europea seguirá haciendo todo
lo que está a su alcance Para apoyar al
valiente pueblo de Ucrania mantendremos
la presión sobre el kremlin todo el
tiempo que sea necesario con un régimen
de sanciones mordaces
extenderemos estas sanciones a quienes
apoyen militarmente a Rusia como belarus
oirán
pero su rol en el conflicto en Ucrania y
la defensa del bloque europeo no fueron
los únicos temas sobre la mesa la
alianza Busca también contrarrestar el
auge del poderío chino en la geopolítica
mundial
También hemos visto a China intentar
cada vez más remodelar el orden
internacional en su beneficio por lo
tanto debemos construir nuestra propia
resiliencia o un reso
un paso más allá para fortalecer la
cooperación fue el pedido de Finlandia y
Suecia de hacer parte de la alianza su
integración es considerada precisamente
como la dirección a seguir para llegar a
un nuevo nivel